what's going on guys so if you didn't
know I'm in the middle of a
collaboration with my movie reviewer
buddies the schmoes know we are
reviewing each previous Superman film
before Man of Steel comes out in June we
already collaborated on the first
Superman film that came out in 1978 and
that review is currently on their
Channel but now they bounce back to my
channel so we can tell you our thoughts
on Superman
- before I give you guys my take though
please enjoy the schmoes review of
Superman - hey Chris it is great to be
on your channel we are the schmoes I am
mark that is Kristian we're very excited
not only on Chris Luckman Channel but to
be talking about arguably the best movie
so far in the Superman franchise
Superman dose looks a lot like your
place we're gonna be talking about
Superman - which for a very long time
was probably my favorite superhero movie
of all time
Wow yeah I loved this movie I couldn't
get enough of this movie and it's it's
funny how this Superman 2 has such a
history behind it it's such an epic
movie it needed two directors to do it
kind of Richard Donner was working on
and then they kicked him up it didn't
like the way things were going so they
brought in some other guy named dick
Lester yeah Donner was like a visionary
and could have and obviously still has
fit into the way today works and these
people were around the that's why the
cheesiness in the corniness came from
the other side when you see Donna's
cutter super into it's a darker side so
we're just going to kind of talk about
Superman too as a whole we might cross
over Donna's cut a little bit more what
I love about Superman 2 in general was
the fact that the met the main bad guys
are the ones in the very first scene of
Superman 1 it was really neat the way
they set that up we see Marlon Brando in
the first one cast these three really
evil looking people into outer space and
then they find they land on earth thanks
to Superman threw a missile out into
space and blew up and shot them down to
earth
lo and behold they're gonna go to the
White House and make that kneel before
Zod yeah I mean it's a whole first scene
in the beginning with the astronauts and
you just you see the land on the moon
and the reason why again yes because
Superman has to take this whole thing in
the very beginning in Paris and he takes
the nuclear explosion it blows up and
then they break out of the prison and
all hell breaks loose and I love when
the three of them get there and they
kind of discover okay this is on the
exact opposite of Superman yeah there
was the big nuclear explosion outer
space there was apparently a little
explosion in Superman
pants because he has really had an
affinity for Lois Lane so much so that
he decides to renounce his powers as
Superman just to be with this brought
soup we need you
there's a couple of things in this movie
that you go ah because in time for women
he cuz you know Superman he gets his
powers away then he gets his ass kicked
all over a diner which is what way let's
talk about that because I love that see
not only is it a cool song from average
white band it's also you see this guy
and I love seeing the looking court
Kent's face where he's like I know that
this guy doesn't stand a chance against
me when I need but this is not who I am
me getting the crap kicked out of me in
this Idaho bar it's not me no and again
we've talked about this many times but
the reason I enjoy this movie so much is
because when you character like Superman
who's as big a larger-than-life you have
to have a great villain and Lex Luthor
yeah he's a great villain and he's in
this gene Hackman is yet again but it's
odd Zod owns this movie everyone
remembers Zod kneel before Zod yeah he's
the medicine villain and the other two
aren't bad either and then we had this
huge showdown at the fortress of
solitude why once he gets his powers
back yeah everybody's involved yeah yeah
and don't forget mr. metropolis yeah oh
yeah yeah but you're the coolest scenes
ever because and it was film still it's
not a modern-day movie but it was one it
really still sucks you up even though
the special effects aren't quite on the
par anymore it's still neat to see all
this stuff visually and it's a lot
darker again like if you watch the
Donner cut of Superman 2 they take
different cuts from his from what he
wanted to do and from what they used in
the other cut and you could see like the
serious kind of tone that he was going
for and it's a bit more menacing with
what Zod was doing the pure domination
and wanted kal-el just a kneel before
him son of our jailer
kneel before Zod and he gets so intent
and it's like yeah it's all very epic
stuff and it is a great showdown at the
end and it's a credit to Christopher
Reeve as Clark Kent slash Superman that
he was able to pull off this darker tone
and be more vulnerable even as a
superhero and you know the movies were
filmed like two years apart it was like
it was the Donner cut and then they had
to shelve it for a while to get Lester
back on there so gene Hackman refused to
work for the other guy for Lester he's
in it as much unless you watch the
donger cut so either one's really good
it's very cool I want to go back and
revisit the donger cut I remember liking
the donger cut a little bit more but
which is stupid because I five out of
five smell both of these yeah I'm gonna
go I'm gonna go five out of five for
Superman two as well it's dated love
course it's dated but it is one of those
movies just again it was it was
everything I remember as a superhero
that I wanted to see that I didn't get
in the first one it's well who's gonna
be able to beat Superman well you have
three of them I got a way that you can
watch those other two you go revisit
them right now stop yappin and we'll
turn it back over to Kris how's that
sound Oh a hand moving I got it thanks
Kris now your take to me it is honestly
a miracle that Superman 2 is a good
movie because all the production
problems that went on during this movie
Richard Donner the original director of
the first film actually leaving the
production being replaced with another
guy who had never even heard of Superman
before in his life somehow this movie
actually turned out good it is truly a
miracle this movie introduces a new
villain for Superman to actually fight
General Zod and he was set up in the
beginning of the first film when him and
his little cohorts were trapped in the
Phantom Zone
floating around in space when they
escape and come to earth and start to
wreak havoc this starts a war between
General Zod and Superman but it's not
just between Superman Zod wants the
entire planet to kneel before him he
wants to be a ruler of Earth however at
the same time and unfortunately not at a
very good time for Superman he decides
to give up his powers to be with Lois
Lane because he really really really
likes Lois Lane apparently this creates
a lot of drama a lot of tension and some
really fun action sequences and Superman
to a movie that in my opinion isn't
quite as good as the first one but I
still enjoy the film quite a bit there's
times when I watch this movie where you
can kind of see different opinions
clashing which is obvious because the
director changed halfway through and
they reshot things and they change
things and Richard Lester the director
who came in on this movie who then later
directed Superman 3 which we'll talk
about soon over on the schmoes channel
he came in and he had a very different
idea of how to direct this movie he
wanted to make it look as much like a
comic book as possible and since comic
book panels are just still static shots
he wanted to do a lot of that without
too much panning without too much movie
shot so to speak that's an interesting
idea but I feel like maybe he could have
directed it with some more Flair
honestly comic book movies were very new
that time Superman in the movie is
really the first one to do it really
well I think a lot of people were still
a little confused about how they could
actually make one of these movies and I
think it would have been a better film
of Richard Donner had stayed on it was
allowed to do his full ideas which by
the way we do have a way of sort of
seeing his idea and the Richard Donner
cut of Superman - which in my opinion is
much better than the theatrical cut
Christopher Reeve is still fantastic as
Superman here and one of the best parts
of his character in this movie is that
conflict between wanting to be human and
still being Superman giving up his
powers below its lane or keeping them
having to save metropolis or care for
Lois Lane as a human there's some really
great scenes here where he doesn't have
his powers that are actually pretty
heartbreaking and Superman too did a
really good job of portraying that
character as he is in the comics but
also giving him a fun villain to fight
rather than some wealthy landowner the
movie still has some of the same issues
the first one has nowadays which really
isn't entirely its fault and that is
that the special effects appear a little
bit dated some of the humor is a little
dated and that's just going to happen
but overall I do feel that that first
film is slightly better than this one
because that origin story was told with
so much care and because it was great to
have John Williams actually composing
the music because he didn't actually
compose the music for Superman to
someone else imitated his themes all in
all I'm going to give Superman to a
b-plus it's still a very good Superman
movie and I suggest you guys check it
out if you were interested in that
character the schmoes in my review of
Superman 3 is going to be on their
channel in a few days please go over
there and check it out when it's up
thanks as always for watching guys and
if you like this you can click right
here and get stuck mine eyes
[Music]
Oh